all right let's have a little fun here a
unit before we get to some serious stuff
you know that one of my favorite things
if you watch my live streams is When
Donald Trump has technical problems with
his audio and it actually happens a lot
incredible oh these people don't know
what the hell they're doing further
scream that his days are numbered
[Music]
deal that included the largest
agricultural
Farm product okay but I think Eric
they're not like they lived up I used to
check it every week are they buying are
they buying Okay so yesterday apparently
in the middle of thinking he's very
close to getting arrested Donald Trump
called in to some pastors for Trump show
I don't even know how he gets booked on
this stuff to be totally honest and it's
all really weird and about 50 seconds in
when they ask him for a prayer call the
audio just goes completely crazy and
then Trump claims that the radical
left-hacked him it's let's just listen
and we are ready to introduce the
president of the United States by the
way the pr the president I thought the
president of the United States is Joe
Biden isn't it Donald J Trump is coming
on live with us the 45th and going to be
the 47th president of the United States
of America president Trump welcome to
pastors for Trump National Prayer call
for you how are you doing sir I'm doing
well Jackson I appreciate it and it's an
honor to be with you and I just heard a
great General Flynn and my friend Rogers
so we already have the echo but this is
nothing compared to what happens I was
very honored to give them full pardons
because they were treated horribly by
government these radical left lunatics
and uh full pardons they're almost as
clean as you are right now Jackson
category okay but uh they're two
terrific people that really suffered
greatly at the hand of crazy people so
this was my uh my great honor and Clay
thank you very much for the great job
you've done at Kristin Davis we
appreciate it very much very much but
president Trump I wanted to uh tell you
I I was in my my wife and I were
attending the NCAA wrestling event in
Tulsa Oklahoma and we can see you and
all I could say is that my wife and I
Pastor Jackson everybody out there is
praying for you and I think a lot of
people are looking for a specific uh sir
um what is the prayer that you would
like for the thousands of pastors who
are tuning in right now what are the
specific prayer requests that you have
tonight sir
hmm
this is all still live remember
they can't hear that
that's Trump saying they can't hear that
somebody's working on something
very very important stuff here
some people thought maybe Trump got
arrested and that's why he went quiet
but that was seemingly not the case
uh
but more Trump whispering
one of the hosts gives a thumbs up
and they're getting very very close here
to fixing the audio
it's not even really clear what the
problem is because you can hear Trump
kind of breathing in the background
strangely enough
they may not have prayed hard enough for
the audio anyway
everybody's getting upset now
can you imagine waiting all day for your
interview with Trump and then this
happens
okay I guess we have a little phone
miscommunication and I think what
happened is the radical left we can hear
him the radical left was working on the
phone there's no question about it but I
think you heard what I said previously
is that right fellas
hello
okay anyway uh that that's basically
enough now there were people there were
people who wrote to me and said the
reason this happened is because Trump
doesn't like to answer religious
questions right remember this you
mentioned the Bible you've been talking
about how it's your favorite book
said I think last night in Iowa some
people are surprised that you say that
I'm wondering what one or two of your
most favored Bible verses are I wouldn't
want to get into it because to me that's
very personal you know when I talk about
the Bible it's very personal so I don't
want to get into it I don't want to get
into it it means a lot to you that you
think about our site the Bible means a
lot to me but I don't want to get into
specifics all right so anyway I actually
don't think that's what happened I think
that was genuine Tech trouble and I
loved absolutely every second of it